I not very democratic easy to try and
deny the people of UK including the
Scottish people of yes no vote on
staying in Europe well we put forward a
reasoned amendment which said that the
referendum should all those 16 and 17
year olds to vote that people of all
european nationalities should below to
what the Scotland's rates as a nation
could be respected and that the the vote
shouldn't take place in the same days of
scotch elections next year all very
reasonable constructive things to put
forward and a listening government would
have accepted our men that they chose
not to so we voted against yeah but the
fact remains you voted against the
principles of referendum taking place I
agreed you'd like to have amenities at
the margins or that to every other party
Labour Party Liberal Democrats
conservatives say give the people a
choice yeah but unfortunately you gave
the vote on our amendment that's the
vote on amendment you just read out yeah
but we fought against the bill because
we went to the general election and
Scotland saying that shouldn't be a
European referendum in the towns
proposed by the conservative party and
we received an overwhelming mandate from
the Scottish people for that and
actually over eighty percent of people
in Scotland in this general election a
few weeks ago voted for parties who were
against having a referendum in these
terms so we were staying faithful to the
electoral mandate given to us by the
Scottish people other parties can speak
and what I do more in principle is the
reason for not having a friend Oh bit
what principle the you have referendum
when you you have something to propose
to honest love lane and Audi no no no
that's not what's been poppin well let
me finish the point at us if you've got
actually begging okay if you believe in
Scottish independence and that's what
you're proposing or if you believe the
Scottish devolution are well established
or proportional representation and you
see that's my proposition can you back
and get backing for it through the
sovereignty the people that is a proper
referendum but nobody believes the Prime
Minister wants to withdraw from the
European Union he's actually proposing a
referendum but something he doesn't want
to do not a bit something he does want
to do that's why there's an internal
contradiction at the very heart of this
rifle in the process and that's why for
example but that is no but that's
exactly what the government did in
Scotland the government wanted to
preserve the Union but the question was
no sorry we the government the
government don't hear didn't run the
Scottish referendum well they described
not I mean constitutionally they did
they got permission
they place which made no one I spent an
entire Indian correcting you in fact but
what happened was the Scottish
Government were given the post to hold
the referendum I remember this I was
first minister we held a referendum on a
proposition of Scottish independence I
was in fear as a prop is not a
proposition like no it should the UK
stay in no no that's not a proposition
the proposition on the ballot paper
sorry isn't the proposition the ballot
paper is to stay in is not to change not
to withdraw haven't you read the
question Adam that's why I say the
consequences of voting yeah would be
that the UK would come out you asked you
a point to point a brightening thick
tonight right well I couldn't possibly
comment you might see that but the two
things that one we have a mandate from
the people to pause the referendum these
terms and secondly I don't believe it's
a proper referendum for somebody to put
forward a referendum to see off UK to
pacify his own party when he doesn't
actually believe in withdraw it doesn't
believe in the proposition that people
are getting the chance to vote on know
what I think would be of some interest
your viewers tonight might be to know
that I think it's pretty clear that the
government doesn't have a majority to
force through what they've been
suggesting over the last few days they
might hold the referendum on the same
day as the Scottish and Welsh elections
i think that's devastatingly clear and
secondly there's a widespread concern i
think majority i can say i'm in the
house of commons not to allow the
suspension of pub of papaya of the rules
of Stan's admission was passed by a
majority of 491 and it wasn't far off
for the your motion either say no so can
you were you were trying to say they
shouldn't hold it there yes and what I'm
saying to you now Adam and you can bring
me back you're safe a majority I'm sorry
where's the evidence well you should
have sat and listened to the debate as I
did and talk to the people of putting it
forward I'm saying it looks to me like
this a majority in the House of Commons
who against holding this around
referendum on the same day as the
Scottish Welsh and no amount elections
that came from the government's not
saying that so well the government
wouldn't rule out Adam and that's why
I'm saying if the government persist in
refusing to rule out then they face
while they face defeat of retreat a
committee of report stage I also think
there's widespread concern but this
attempt
spend the rules of holding referendum
and although I'm passionately in favor
of European Union far more than feeble
in the Prime Minister's I don't agree
with governments trying to reg
referendums because we had experience of
what happens in a referendum when the
civil service stop being impartial we've
had experience or what happens in
referendum when Pitt when governments
ignore pub the periods as the
Westminster Government did last I see it
true is the Labour whips are claiming
tonight that your leader in the Commons
Angus Robertson went into the wrong
division lobby and then try to hide in
the lavatory it's absolutely no idea of
what so ever but I always treat anything
because I just notice you are actually a
vote down well let me say well it is
certainly true is that Labour Party and
the Conservatives found themselves in
the same lobby once again just like they
did in the Scottish referendum campaign
which is why I suspect the Bellator
supported II has the SMB its sixty
percent 60 sexual percent supports final
question when it comes to holding this
referendum and obviously there's a lot
more skilled in Parliament in the Lord's
in particular and then coming back to
the Commons but assuming that the
referendum in some form comes through
will you or nicola sturgeon or other SMP
colleagues appear on platforms with
conservative or labour colleagues in
support of staying in the EU I mean I I
think there's no chance of a joint
campaign and the reason for it is it's
quite simple that the reasons that we
have for supporting the European Union
and about what we think Europe should be
doing positive things like you look
should be doing more than the
environment they should be helping these
desperate people in the Mediterranean
the Prime Minister's case is about what
Europe shouldn't be doing and I think
before better if there's a distinctive
Scottish Scotland in Europe campaign so
I think a joint campaign it's for the
but that was what I asked though I mean
we might have joined rally a yes rally
where you all appear together could that
happen well I doubt it because the two
cases are so different I think it's far
better to have a distinctive Scottish
yes campaign and instantly I don't think
the campaign has gotten to be led by
petitioner I think there's plenty of
people beyond politics one of the
lessons from the referendum was the
engagement of people well outside the
usual political Nexus I think we'll go
down that road I can certainly tell you
having a let's say the chance for this
checker on a yes broadcast in Scotland
don't like a ton of bricks got a name
yes a for the yes what they've been for
us will be Scott Lagoona name to need it
oh no I couldn't possibly nominee and I
even in your illustrious proof okay well
thank you for being with us great
pleasure